hey gang it's an basher here again with
another MCU video what a twist
we have multiple Marvel movies coming
out every year a multitude of Marvel
tie-in shows on different networks and
the content just keeps on coming these
Marvel films and shows are meant to
exist in the same universe the idea that
one day all these characters could
interact together would be incredible
that being said when you have that many
people there's always a chance of plot
holes yes even the MCU is susceptible to
them even one glaring one in Avengers
infinity war I'll just say it right now
why didn't Doctor Strange before to
slice Thanos his arm off let's talk
about some of the biggest potholes in
the MCU that I was able to find and
discuss them here's your spoiler warning
for the entirety of the MCU and Marvel
Comics let's begin with the one that's
been confusing me for a while how do Pym
particles work they don't they're in the
movie ant-man a Hank Pym states that he
learned how to change the distance
between atoms which does sound cool in a
movie but that doesn't explain how the
original wasp and Scott Lang were able
to enter the quantum realm or go
subatomic
I know there's a deeper explanation of
how Pym particles work in the comics but
just based on how Hank described them in
the film moving on Iron Man's suit needs
a recharge now in Iron Man 3 one of the
main plot points is that Tony's suit
needs to recharge with car battery
however up until Iron Man 3 all this
suits were running off of arc reactors
specifically is the one nestled in his
chest that was saving his life now the
suits don't need to run off of Tony's
specific reactor since we saw an army of
Iron Man suits fighting the mandarins
forces during the movie's finale but why
does it need to charge with car battery
some Tony just plug that sucker into his
chest just saying next how long does
Doctor Strange train for now in Doctor
Strange is standalone film it's
extremely tough to nail down when the
movie exactly takes place there are some
teases that possibly this happens after
the events of Civil War with the mention
of the pilot spine being injured due to
an experimental armor or possibly that's
after the events of Iron Man 2 with the
hammer tech knockoff armor being tested
and turning that guy like a pretzel but
there's no real way to really pin it
down also the training montage isn't
quite clear as to how long it takes
strange is mastering the mystic arts and
while he is an extremely intelligent
person very capable it should take him
probably a couple of years right there's
also a mention of the Avengers in the
film so some of the story takes place
after the events of the first Avengers
film you see what I mean it kind goes
all over the place if you want to know
more about
timeline of the MCU check out Eric's
comprehensive video on it's very good
next Howard starts model molecule so
you're telling me that Howard Stark
Papa Stark somehow hid the exact right
element inside of a model of the stark
Expo that would save Tony's life in the
future from very specific metal
poisoning it's very convenient
next how did the Avengers lose Loki's
staff after the events of the Avengers
during the finale of that movie Thor
takes Loki and the tesseract back to
Asgard but leaves the staff now there's
a chance that they could have lost that
staff in the fight but they spent most
of the movie studying that staffs power
source so couldn't they have built some
sort of sci-fi scanner looking for it in
New York it couldn't have gone far am i
right I just feel like Thor should have
been on the lookout for that when he was
leaving Earth anyways moving on another
Avengers question why did they else give
up his only infinity stone to a random
guy that he has just recruited why not
to one of his children who seemed a
little bit more capable than Loki but
even then why would you give up an
infinity stone I'm guessing he was
expecting to get it back it was a loan
to Loki if he succeeded but next let's
talk about the most confusing plot hole
the eight years later line and
spider-man homecoming has everyone
confused it makes zero sense the Russo
brothers were asked about the time jump
during an interview and they stated oh
it was eight years I believe and it was
quite controversial yes it was a very
incorrect eight years so let's just
chalk that up to being a mistake because
it's starting to hurt my brain next
where did the gauntlet come from no here
comes infinity Wars plot holes we find
out in the movie that Thanos went to
nineveh Lear and had the dwarves make
him a gauntlet that could house the
stones and wield them however there was
already a gauntlet in Odin's vault with
all of the stones in place we figured
out that that is a fake later on in
Ragnarok but still also Thanos already
had a gauntlet during the post-credits
scene of age of ultron based on what
each read Peter Dinklage's character
stated it sounds like it was rather
recent that they most came and kill all
the dwarves or at least after slash
during the events of Ragnarok Thanos
went to Nineveh Lear and kill all the
dwarves and created the gauntlet so what
were the other two did they nose get the
idea of the gauntlet from somewhere else
has it been used before by other beings
why didn't have a fake one was a nurse's
gauntlet in age of Ultron the one that
we saw in infinity war probably but that
means the Asgardians haven't been
listening to the cries of the other
realm
for some time now finally here's the big
one I mentioned before why did dr.
strange not cut off his arm with the
sling ring magic portal device the sling
ring was able to cut off the arm of coal
obsidian a being that seemed to be
almost as strong as the Hulk or close to
it now infinity war we see that
sometimes when Thanos uses the gauntlet
you can see some of the energy moving
down his arm but does that mean that his
whole body is protected once he wears
the gauntlet no because he still is cut
by Tony Stark so he's not totally
invulnerable he's pretty strong but I do
want to say when they knock Thanos out
and they try to pull the karlon off of
him why not take that opportunity when
he's not focused it just chop it off but
anyways those are the biggest plot holes
that I was able to find that really
bugged me but here are a few honorable
mentions really quick
why wasn't vision in Lagos in the
beginning of Captain America's Civil War
he would have been a big help why
rebuild the Bifrost after the events of
the first Thor movie Thor got to earth
and Avengers without it fors
age we see Thor as a child who didn't
experience the war between the frost
giants and Asgard on earth but then we
see a story book that chronicles Thor's
adventures on earth even though he's
still a young man in that movie by
Asgardian standards but there you have
it those of the plot holes that really
irked me let me know which ones bugged
you or other ones that I didn't bring up
in the comments down below be sure to
check out all of our other Marvel
content and more by subscribing the new
rock stars IMATS and bash are on twitter
follow me send me your thoughts check
out my podcast only stupid answers if
you want to have more Marvel talk and
I'll see you guys next time bye bye